with Avengers in game being out on
digital HD we now have a ton of
commentary about the movie from the
directors from the writers from the
producers and we are finally getting
answers to questions that we've had for
a very long time since Avengers end game
came out in theaters how's it going
everybody it's Warren and it's nice to
finally get some answers to some burning
questions about Avengers in game from
the people who made the movie themselves
one of the most epic and shocking scenes
of Avengers in game was when Thanos
broke Captain America shield with his
sword
it's shocking not only because they
covered up the broken shield in the
trailers with CGI but also because
vibranium is supposed to be unbreakable
and is supposed to be the strongest
metal out there remember it is an alien
metal it did come from space a meteor
hit Wakanda and that's how they got
vibranium
so how was Stannis able to break Captain
America shield that made out of
vibranium luckily for us the writers of
Avengers in game have chimed in and told
us out before we dive into it if you'd
like a chance to win an Xbox one or a
ps4 be sure to subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your favorite superhero or villain so
you can enter my giveaway if you have
read the Infinity Gauntlet saga comics
you know that Thanos breaks Captain
America's shield and there as well
however he simply uses his bare hands in
the comics to shatter the shield now
obviously in the movie they gave Thanos
a huge sword that was able to break
Captain America's shield and according
to the commentary for Avengers in Game
wild vibranium is the strongest metal on
earth whatever thanasis sword is made of
is stronger and it could be that each
recreated it although this isn't the
most specific answer in the world we do
have our answer thanassis sword is
simply made out of a material that is
stronger than vibranium well what could
a stronger material than vibranium be
well they do mention Eitri which means
that they are implying that thanasis
sword is made out of metal and that each
remade it for him now this makes perfect
sense because Thanos clearly knew who
Eitri was because he went to Eitri to
make the Infinity Gauntlet in fact an
Avengers endgame rocket and Thor make it
pretty clear that Eitri and the dwarves
of neduvaali are pretty well known for
making the strongest weapons in the
universe so it seems very clear that
Thanos would know who
tree was but who's to say that the
Infinity Gauntlet was the very first
weapon that famous went to III for
remember before Fanus learned about the
Infinity stones and retrieved any for
himself his original plan was to go
planet to planet with his army and wipe
out half of the population for each
planet himself once he learned about the
Infinity stones he then went to e tree
to have him forge the Infinity Gauntlet
but before that he needed a weapon to
basically wage war on the whole entire
universe and since the creators of
Avengers endgame are implying that each
recreated this double bladed sword for
Thanos we can put two and two together
and realize that each tree most likely
made this sword for Thanos when Thanos
began his correction of the universe
slaughtering millions going planet to
planet and balancing and correcting the
universe so for all of you wondering how
famous was able to break Captain
America's vibranium shield it's because
his sword was made out of a stronger
metal guru metal made for him by Eitri
himself and sidenote the Scarlet Witch
was able to break his sword which means
that she is just insanely powerful it's
going to be great to see her and dr.
strange to Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness so be sure to let
me know your thoughts on this in the
comments down below and also don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff